[Music]
you know what i can't believe it's been
almost a week not quite a week but
almost a week since the super bowl right
but there's still
controversy about madonna's halftime
show have you heard about this
some people are now saying that
madonna's halftime show was full of
satanic symbolism
yeah and madonna's response to the
accusation was what can i say i owe that
guy everything
i
i had to act it out it was too much fun
there you go mr devil
[Music]
that run
newt gingrich in the news newt gingrich
still battling hard for the republican
nomination doing his best
newt gingrich is trying to uh save his
campaign by focusing only on areas where
he has the most support
yeah so he's mostly focusing on georgia
tennessee and the cheesecake factory
apparently he's a huge there
yeah
he's done enough for them
the devil's with newt at the cheesecake
factory but that's a coincidence yes
they just both eat there
meanwhile mitt romney trying very hard
to connect with voters people say he's
not connecting you know that he seems
like he's too affluent yeah in his
campaign mitt romney has started talking
about his father's humble beginnings as
a carpenter
yeah
he said he said i'll never forget the
day my dad started building our fourth
beach house
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why
why is the devil now in every joke
i don't know
hey i don't hear about this this is
crazy today hundreds of moms around the
world are breastfeeding
outside facebook's offices
to protest the fact that facebook
censors
any pictures of breastfeeding
yeah so they're all outside facebook
offices breastfeeding yeah meanwhile ceo
mark zuckerberg is watching with
binoculars saying my plan worked
perfectly
so that one makes
the devil should be there
[Music]
this is this is the only reason he
created facebook was leading up to this
one oh look at that
that's right mama uh
i apologize
speaking of tech stuff uh developers are
working on an app i couldn't believe
this they're working on an app that will
sense when you are depressed and urge
you to seek help
yeah the app is called the i notice
you're playing a lot of adele
just push it
good enough
this is crazy there is a rise in std
rates among senior citizens
senior citizens coming down with more
stds yeah yeah this is because the only
thing senior citizens will wrap in
plastic is their furniture
[Music]
that was more of a yes it's true
this weekend kfc became the first
american fast food restaurant to open in
palestine
kfc yeah yeah they tried to open a taco
bell but then decided they've had enough
explosions over there
so yeah
[Applause]